the clark county school district taking
now some proactive steps to keep
students and staff safe with a new alert
system victoria saha was able to get a
preview of this earlier today at mojave
high school she joins us now live
tonight here with more victoria
denise nine schools will be utilizing
this pilot program the school district
says their main focus right now are
those bigger high schools with multiple
entry points in case of an emergency
take a look at how it works
your crisis alert badge will work
anywhere on the school campus the system
is called essentials each staff member
will be wearing a land yard with a card
that has a button on it staff can click
on it to initiate a staff alert for
example if there was a fight in a
classroom it could also initiate a
campus-wide emergency lockdown if an
intruder were to build the building this
alert system works through wi-fi and
connects to a hub the hub then starts
activating strobe lights while alerting
campus emergency personnel
superintendent dr jesus jarrow wouldn't
go into detail on how much this is
costing but says he made it a priority
it's reallocating of dollars this is a
priority
our children and our staff need to be
safe we are prioritizing our existing
dollars
to make sure that our staff is safe ccsd
police lieutenant brian zing says his
team is ready to respond immediately for
an emergency and this new tool will be a
great resource to make sure every second
counts every year our officers go
through a very rigorous active assailant
active shooter type training it'll allow
our staff a quick and easy way to alert
us and district leadership that there's
an emergency at a campus after a school
year filled with violence dr jarrah is
hoping this tool will give everyone a
sense of safety next year what we are
looking at is what are the best options
for our students and for our staff we
are moving fast and furious
earlier this year an el dorado high
school teacher was brutally attacked by
a student that school has a different
pilot program that's audio based the
school district will then decide which
program they want to move forward with
reporting from mohave high school
victoria zaha live local now